>> ONE TRUMP GOES TO
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CHURCH AND
TAKES QUESTIONS --
>> Tammy: THANK YOU.
HE TAKES SO MANY QUESTIONS THAT
HAS BEEN, WE ARE WAITING FOR
JOE BIDEN TO TAKE MORE AND MAYBE
WE ARE SEEING WHY HE CAN’T.
WISCONSIN MAY NOT BE THE ONLY
SWING STATE JOE BIDEN HAS TO
WORRY ABOUT.
MINNESOTA MAY NOT BE AS BLUE AS
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN THINKS
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT SIX MAYORS
FROM DEMOCRAT CITIES IN
BLUE-COLLAR IRON MINING
DISTRICTS HAVE DECLARED THEY
WILL BE VOTING FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN NOVEMBER.
IN AN OPEN LETTER, THEY WROTE
"WE DIDN’T CHOOSE TO LEAVE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE PARTY LEFT
US.
WE KNOW THAT AS A STATE FROM
PRESIDENT REAGAN, MANY OF US CAN
RELATE TO THAT.
ONE OF THOSE MAYORS, THE MAYOR
OF BABBITT MINNESOTA JOINS US
NOW, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
IT’S A HEATED TIME FOR THOSE OF
US WHO ENJOY POLITICS, I WANT TO
ASK YOU, HAVE OTHER MAYORS OR
OTHER LOCAL OFFICIALS EXPRESSED
SIMILAR VIEWS TO YOU OR ARE THEY
WORRIED TO SAY THE LEAST ABOUT
WHAT THE ECONOMIC RUIN BIDEN
WOULD BRING?
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
AND WHAT OTHER PEOPLE MAY BE
SAYING TO YOU AT THIS POINT.
>> ALL OF THOSE POINTS, THOSE OF
THE BIGGEST CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
ECONOMY IF IT GOES THE OTHER
WAY.
I CAN TELL YOU ONE MORE MAYOR
HAS STEPPED UP NOW, THERE ARE
SEVEN OF US IN THE GROUP.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE STEPPING UP
MORE NOW AND THEY ARE REALIZING
WE ARE A SILENT MAJORITY AND WE
ARE DONE KEEPING OUR MOUTH
QUIET.
WE NEED TO KEEP GOING FORWARD
AND WE NEED TO KEEP PLUGGING
AWAY, BECAUSE IT’S GOING SO WELL
REGARDLESS OF THE CORONAVIRUS
BUT I FEEL THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
VOTING FOR A TRUMP THAT ARE JUST
LYING LOW RIGHT NOW.
>> Tammy: WOULD YOU SAY
PERHAPS THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
TRANSCEND PARTISAN POLITICS,
THIS IS NOW ABOUT THE FUTURE,
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND THAT IS
WHERE THE COMMITMENT HAS TO BE?
MORE TO THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE
OR TO THE FAMILY THEN PERHAPS
THE PARTY THAT YOU BELONGED TO
FOR SO LONG AS A DEMOCRAT?
>> EVERYONE IS WORKING TOGETHER
AND THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
WE ARE SEEING THE WAY HE HAS
HELPED THE MINORS, EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT IS GOING ON, HE IS
SOMEONE WHO DOES WHAT HE SAYS
HE’S GOING TO DO AND THAT IS
REFRESHING AND NEEDED RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE GOTTEN EMAILS FROM ALL
OVER, ALL WEEK AND I HAD A
GENTLEMAN CALLED ME FROM GEORGIA
TODAY AND HE SAID HE HAD VOTED
FOR OBAMA THE LAST TWO TERMS AND
HE VOTED FOR TRUMP AT THIS TIME,
HE SAID HE’S SICK OF BEING MADE
OUT TO WHERE WE NEED TO MAKE ALL
OF THIS STUFF IN THE
UNITED STATES AGAIN, WE NEED TO
BRING THIS BACK AND THAT
INCLUDES MINING.
WE HAVE THE SAFEST IN MINNESOTA
AND THAT’S WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON.
AND NOT RELY ON OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> Tammy: GREAT STUFF, YOU